I would take the cloned version and I
would make that person spend every
waking moment with my family said hold
you guys what's that why is that funny
and yourself you oh I don't care there
will be no show where you're watching
the show and behind the scenes right now
there's subliminal music pumping by the
damn cat for 999 there is none of that
by this friggin rare toy it's 999 buy it
now side effects may include increase in
heart rate stronger right here heartbeat
difficulty breathing paleness dizziness
weakness or shakiness headache I
prehension nervousness or anxiety Floyd
were breathing in some restrictions
apply see store for details it's
probably very nauseas first of all I'm
so ridiculously jealous that you're 21
it makes me want to vomit on myself I
always say that I'd give up everything
to be 21 and I mean it I love my kids
unconditional if they're schlemiels and
can't sell water in a desert well then
that's just the way it ended up being
the reason I think it feels like I'm not
and so much is getting accomplished is
my pants are on fire true for the thing
that I'd be most important at this exact
moment there is no atmosphere that
dictates my happiness of drinking wine
there's no pretty French Riviera or the
gorgeous mountains I don't give a crap
about that stuff the way I prepare for a
speaking engagement is the same way I
would prepare for war you know I don't
think you understand that the fact that
matter is is they're the same person
maybe I love my business moves in my
favor I would take the equal version of
it and have that person sit at home
every minute and be with my family
because then I would be able to
accomplish the two things that I want at
one time and so that would be the answer